this must end
it is now time to open texas
100 percent texas governor greg abbott
saying his state will open
soon fully and he is causing controversy
of course by ending his state's mass
mandate
president biden scolding texas and
mississippi for lifting mass
restrictions watch this
i think it's a big mistake the last
thing we need is neanderthal thinking
that
in the meantime everything's fine take
off your mask
forget it it still matters and many in
the media are not happy with governor
abbott either
governor abbott has lost his mind this
is obviously
a political ploy on the part of the
governor the only reason i can see
is because of what happened in texas
that someone dropped the ball
and they're trying to change the
conversation that's it a distraction
this is part of this prevailing you know
macho sentimentality
that strong and wrong is the way to go
the texas governor
said covet be dead everybody go ahead
and open up
and you get some coveted you get some
coveted you'll get some coping you'll
get some coven
wow this segment could actually have
been the whole show jesse uh let me
start with you
so one thing that's getting lost is that
the governor was tying his decisions
and maybe didn't explain it well to his
goals for getting
seniors vaccinated and vulnerable
populations to a safe place before
making this order
well some state had to go first it might
as well be texas
the same people complaining about this
were the same people
complaining about georgia when they came
out of the gate first
and none of their predictions came true
they thought everyone down in georgia
was going to drop like flies it didn't
happen he's following the advice of his
medical team
in texas i trust them that's what
governors do they're going to take the
lead on this
and then other governors can see how
this played out i hate to say dana i was
in charts all day at the new york times
website
johnny's eyes were falling out of his
skull every single state
had the same exact trend no matter mass
mandate or not
it went a surge in the spring summer
then down in the fall
and then super surge in the winter and
then it just falls off a cliff
precipitously
no matter what you do these are some
boring numbers
last month texas had thirty thousand
cases a day today they have five
thousand cases
deaths are cut in half hospitalizations
fifteen thousand to five thousand
texas is doing fantastic i saw newsom
wagging
his little finger at abbott where does
he come off texas is beating california
in pretty much every single metric and
their economy is doing better
the major clusters in texas are the
nursing homes and the prisons
i'm sure people will still be wearing
masks there if you go to a restaurant
dana
you put your mask on you fake it until
you walk to the table and then you rip
it off and you guzzle wine and have some
i don't know steak and potatoes and then
you put the mask on when you walk to the
bathroom
and then you leave it's a joke i've done
this you've done this
everybody's done this i've never seen
people complain
that the government is not forcing them
to do something
texans can still wear masks if they want
to yeah yeah we in fact we interviewed
someone today on this on the
america's newsroom and she owns a
restaurant enchiladas olay which sounds
amazing
she said that you know they're gonna
still wear masks greg because she thinks
that
that's the right thing to do for her
restaurant she's gonna be socially
distant
uh the word neanderthal let me tell you
that that would get that's some fighting
words greg because
that gets to people in texas to think
don't mess with us
i mean what a surprise though it's
always about people
with democrats you're deplorable you're
unsalvageable you're a neanderthal
you're probably a white supremacist
guilty of white privilege they only
smear populations whereas if you listen
to jesse just now
he brings up newsome we don't bring up
californians we talk about cuomo we
don't talk about new yorkers we talk
about joe we don't talk about the united
states we talk about the mayor of
portland we focus on peop
on the actual individuals we don't go
after biden voters
right uh or californians um but here's
the issue with people like
joe biden and and uh in those clones
you can't win against the wait till it's
100
safe argument because it will never be
100 safe that's the prison of two ideas
that's why joe said hey maybe everything
will be okay
by next year this time we saw this
coming
we knew this because leaders and the
media both have no
skin in this game they have jobs they
have exemptions
they have kids in private schools and
tutors they could go on forever
and they'll be just great but i want to
i want to talk about texas just quickly
if texas were a person it's the person
who leaves
the lost group of hikers to go and seek
help it's the person who assumes the
risk first
on behalf of others the state actually
stepped up
you need texas in a world of leaders
who have no problem shutting down things
indefinitely
and the media the media is that person
in every disaster movie
that needs to be slapped by the hero
stop
panicking like like gene hackman in the
beside it adventure is texas
and the and and the media or the people
going i don't know what to do
and you have to go man pull yourself
together yes hey
one there are 14 other states i believe
that didn't have a mass mandate
either are they do you think that
they're going to get the neanderthal
label
uh i don't like the label like you don't
but i must say uh i think in those other
states they have not done away they
haven't said we're open
uh you know in that way so what what to
me look i think this is a sign of
progress
that you know texas thinks oh yeah we
can do this now
it may be premature i think it's uh
you know to my mind it's a sign of
impatience on the governor's part
but i think it's a sign of progress in
the sense that we are do you see
declining rates of infection
in the country right now in texas new
covent cases you know
right now they're down i think it's 70
since inauguration day since biden took
office if you want to put it that way
but that's true for us all so i think a
lot of people are like optimistic
they're saying hey
the spring is coming you know the sun is
out okay the numbers are going down
and so we can do it but i think you know
look a lot of this is left over from
trump he mishandled the pandemic
his own poster said he thinks that's why
he lost the election
and uh and now you have people saying
hey look things like you know biden took
the bull by the horns maybe we can just
do what we want to do but i think that's
a mistake
katie i hope that reopening states so
that economies can get
back uh going and businesses can open
aren't it's not going to become
the political like political like
everything else
yeah well the media is already making it
political as if they know better
uh you know unless they're going to
start covering the fact that the biden
administration is allowing
covid infected migrants illegal
immigrants to get on buses to spread
this disease to other people
they have no business talking about any
of this and also why is joe biden still
wearing a mask
he's been vaccinated like this virtue
signaling that continues on
is just really getting tiresome and
dates aren't opening
only because because cases are going
down they're opening because the people
are demanding that their government be
representative of them
and stop infringing on their ability to
make money and to make a living so it's
a combination of all those things okay
next up here's a phrase i never thought
i'd say dropping